hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
I am farther than I've ever been in the
game ever also I happen to be on the
precipice of destruction and I'm
probably going to die yes hi hello yes
so I'm gonna give you a tour of the base
and what it's for thus far because I've
made a lot of progress I've built a lot
of [ __ ] I've got a lot of duplicates I
have a lot of problems but it's fine
everybody hold on hold on before you get
into any of the Oh No markiplier is
being an idiot again I'm not being an
idiot I have some not quite
sophisticated a net person might not
call these solutions sophisticated but
they are imaginative solutions to many
problems that have been arisen in this
game so pay close attention because I'm
gonna give a quick tour a quick overview
and you will quickly how royally boned
I actually am so yes 99 problems
I wish alright so let's start over in
I'll go top to bottom first of all space
is within our grasp
it's tantalizingly close it's so just
oh it's tipped asler tantalizingly close
it's just right there that space and I
could go to space at any moment if I
wanted to bust through this and lose all
my oxygen to the vacuum of space which
would be real bad but other than that
other than doing that thing that I
shouldn't do I've got multiple access to
snow biomes there's a volcano in the
middle of this one I don't know why
there is a chlorine gas vent there's a
whole bunch of other stuff but first and
foremost this is my first expansion area
this is the area that I'm kind of like
pushing out thank you accident this is
kind of where I'm pushing out here to
kind of give myself a noob
and it didn't work out quite 100% the
way the way I thought it was because I
thought I would have done it a little
bit smarter I've cleaned out all the
germs in here and stuff like that if you
remember in the in the earlier stage of
the game like germs were a big problem
there's still a problem but I've managed
to solve the problems for the most part
here's my main base I've got some beds
bunks here growing some food here you
can see the first of many problems is
that these food sources are too hot the
temperature has just been steadily
climbing in here and I was working so
hard on a project way down south that I
completely ignored the fact that there
was a problem up here which there is but
that's not the main problem that I'm
talking about I've got a lot more
problems with which you're gonna see
very soon so just buckle the [ __ ] up
because it's about to get bad so here's
my main biggest problem my main big
problem the biggest big problem that
I've got so big boy problem this is my
oxygen production facility it
electrolyzers water so you've got water
this is the pumping system that I got in
here all the shower toilets all provided
by this one pump here but the main big
big big big big big problem is it's
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
it's 50s my the oxygen I'm producing is
fifty five degrees Celsius I've got two
two HVAC ski and I tried an emergency
solution by putting ice on top of this
thing you know cuz I thought that maybe
you would trickle some cold back and I'm
melting I right now to try to get that
to kind of sploosh cold water down in
here but it's really hot and that's
what's causing the temperature to rise
here because originally I had an HVAC
system I have a very very quote not
sophisticated but interesting HVAC
system provides what's supposed to be
colder air to my facility here but it
just gets warmer and warmer because this
place gets warmer and warmer I had four
wheeze words it was just if you don't
know it wheeze warts are there these
plants that make it colder which is why
the temperature overlay you see that
these pockets are a little colder
but I don't have enough of them to
provide a cooling for the entire system
so um a little bork my mic is wait my
mic is clipping what's wrong with my mic
what's going on is it broken my kitchen
I can't hear it what's wrong with it
please tell me it's not broken I'm
trying so hard no what is it
what's wrong I can't hear it I don't I
can't hear myself that's the thing hello
hello hello hello god [ __ ] dammit
is it better oh god I can hear myself
now that's not right hang on hang on
hang on is it better is it better
is it better is it better is it better
alright you guys need to bear with me is
it better is it better is it better
is it better is it better now so hard a
drug so hard guys I just watch better is
it better is it better guys and you hear
me am i coming through okay this is
alright for you okay alright so like I
said this is the most progress we've
ever made in the history of forever and
listened when I'm just look at me
looking if you're not looking at me when
I say we are inches away from death we
have no life we have no chance we should
all abandon ship before we die
okay huh now I haven't even gotten to
the main problem some of you eagle-eyed
viewers out there might notice already
that the main problem is this I have 20
duplicants we've only got that much food
thank you trenton we've got we've got
seven thousand two hundred calories the
reason is I was working on a system down
here here's I've got some plastic
manufacturing all that [ __ ] also
contributing to the whole it's getting
[ __ ] hot problem but that aside we're
not gonna worry about that immediately
now it's really getting hot it's really
good toasty your guts it's way too
toasty in there but the main problem is
I was working on this system down here
trying to get steam engine working and I
think what happened was I released so
much steam that it just caused this
flood of heat to come straight up into
my base and how and now I'm so I've got
emergency solutions
I do have emergency solutions I do
so okay together you can do this you can
save them these duplicates are reminding
on you relying on me reminding to rely
on you I will let him die I can't let
them die I won't I can okay I'm so glad
that when I pushed that button it puts
up the screen is like a black screen and
you guys can't hear me because you'd
think I was pretty crazy also I need to
remind I need to inform you guys about
the travaglio situation
so we've got we've got we've got better
trip Aldo and we've got Rivaldo 2.9 here
it's a better was the first from all the
second Travolta traval de who ripped
Rivaldo everyone please give a ripped
Rivaldo please give a ripped Rivaldo for
Travolta traval dough was a [ __ ]
idiot
I can't believe traval dough was such an
but he was unbelievably he was i've got
natural gas leaking in which is not good
oh that's a lot of natural gas but I'm
not worried about it
because it's fine so traval though the
stupid idiot that he was why do we not
have enough oxygen oh no also we're not
producing enough oxygen why - I know why
because I destroy the algae the oxidize
arboga doesn't have any more algae well
we got a little bit ok alright so
emergency solution right hear me out on
this one because it's about to get all
right so there's another there's another
solution that I'm gonna have what I'm
gonna do is we're going to start mining
out the ice the ice in this area I want
to harvest so that we can have more ice
and basically I was putting these here
so we didn't get flooded before but I'm
gonna destroy him for now because I
don't think this volcano is gonna melt
this that was a problem that I thought
was a bigger problem than it was but
it's not that big of a problem so it's
okay so we're gonna we're gonna destroy
these what I'm gonna do is we're gonna
we're gonna we're in a strip mine this
we're gonna strip mine this area right
here we're just gonna make make
ourselves some sweet tasty delicious ice
and then I'm gonna do the same solution
that I was doing for I don't even know
if that solution was working but we're
gonna we're gonna do that cuz that's
what I feel like doing so we're just
gonna do it break - no don't go -
don't go to bed death is upon us death
is upon us what do you do don't go to
bed death is upon us you can't sleep not
now see look the ice is melting and it's
making everything cold here which i
think is good so what am I do is once
these these are built so I'm just gonna
make it so that ice but I'm only gonna
limit it to like 500 kilograms of ice
and then each of these is gonna 500
kilograms the water's gonna leak out the
water will eventually you know keep
everything nice and cool and then
that'll prevent like a big source of the
heat that's coming up from below because
heat rises heat rises heat rises okay
so this is the main issue the food
production is not nearly enough
I built this area out to be a farming
area but right now it's just not it's
just there's just no way that I could
grow anything here because it's too hot
now there's probably some plants that I
could make that are hot so let me let me
actually attack this from every front
that I possibly could I don't want to I
don't want to exclude any option right
now just because like if I do then I
know that's going to be something that's
just gonna bite me in the ass so let's
try not to do that what does this have
no power no power what this is no power
what does this have no power where's the
power pump power to it why is it Oh cuz
I got them in the wrong oh well that's
dumb because I've got it wrong stupid
things they're alright whatever fine
it's fine can you cancel that
okay I mean I'll be fine that's that's
not what I'm worried about right now
I've got so many more issues than I'm
worried about
are you kidding me who dig holes you dig
holes you got stuck God you don't get
more stuck gozman oh gee kids okay
chicas right here chicas right here I'm
yelling I'm sorry chica it's okay it's
fine everything's fine everything's fine
everything's fine
three things great get gasping out of
there because I'm fine we started us off
way too way too energetically I this is
fine
fine everything's fine everything's fine
I'm losing my mind I'm losing my mind
because these people just it's like they
want to die it's like they want back
it's just like they want to die that's
all they want
that's all they want so I'm just gonna
copy settings these are gonna be is
gonna be priority 9 level of of that is
gonna be a priority 9 but I'm gonna keep
this it's just like okay so this is good
so this it's getting colder see it works
just soak it in ice - so key soak that
[ __ ] in ice and bada bing bada boom bada
boom bada boom we got it all [ __ ]
starvation oh no put on your big-boy
pants
Elian body there's food right on the
vine just like grapes you pull it right
off punch it right in your mouth off
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's plenty of food there's plenty of
food there's plenty of food there's
plenty of food see no one's starving
anymore no one's starving starvation all
gone
starvation has been beaten guys we did
it we did it we starved
we didn't starve okay everyone's being
you're all being too crazy right now
you're being ridiculous you need to
focus you need to reel it in you need to
get it get your head out of your ass and
you just need to like think patiently
and cautiously about what we're doing
and why we're doing it okay all right
because you're being all oh why why does
this keep breaking why does that keep
breaking that makes no sense why does
that keep breaking there's not it's not
even saying remotely of the what that is
why is that breaking so [ __ ] that's fine
fine everybody just focus just focus
just focus I'm not responsible for
feeding you you do or not I don't feed
you you are not the one I feed oh okay
I'm not feeding you you are not my
responsibility I don't feed you I won't
feed you I'm attacking this from
multiple prongs I've got multiple prongs
of attack that's what I've got
I'm gonna build a goddamn green house
that's what I'm gonna build
I'm gonna build it right here this is
gonna be my other green house it's gonna
be nice and cold it's gonna be cold so
cold it's gonna be frigid no you know it
doesn't even need to be cold Oh God what
food shortage I
we're I'm aware I'm aware of food
shortage I know you call me short you
call me short ass [ __ ] starving starving
serving how's this doing though see look
look look it's keeping it cold that's
good it's it's like a wall of cold to
prevent you know you know it's like it's
cold
just cold it's cold it's cold I feel
death encroaching it's okay
I gotta I gotta snap out of it we can
make this we can survive we can do this
you know why cuz I believe in the heart
of the cards I believe in the heart of
my cards I believe in my hearts cards
starvation is fine they're not starving
how much food you got 900 okay you're
gonna last one more cycle I think we've
got some growers here oh yeah we've got
some growers okay we've got some growers
here we're really gonna really gonna
grow up some grub we're gonna grow up
some grub and this is gonna be fine
because we're also gonna grow up more
grub oh wait we murder more I forgot
about the other option murder forgot
about the one obvious option murder what
guys we've got such we got so much more
that we could do murder her we can kill
things you you're done you're dead you
you're dead you you're dead oh you two
are definitely dead oh the joys of
murder
I forgot how could I forget that
how can I forget that murder we won't
starve if we just kill everything it's
such an obvious so why didn't I think of
it why didn't why didn't I
I'm so foolish I'm so foolish
what else can I kill what else can i
kill
besides my duplicants I would never kill
my do oh yeah I forgot about these ones
there's some dreck O's in here there's
some wild records that are just embedded
in this one ok murderer they're glum
they're glum they're confined free them
and then kill them this is great this is
perfect this is exactly what we did it
oh look at all this tasty delicious
hey we could harvest these two we could
harvest them how do you harvest them
harvest all right got that sleet wheat
harvest all right I feel like I must
have dug up all the sleet wheat that was
up here accidentally quote-unquote
accidentally okay what if I harvest and
harvest
combat yes I mean oh no I'm so sick
combat
yes everything coming yes finally combat
just come food is on the meats back on
the menu boy yes who food here - food
here Oh
combat oh no why oh why is it come to
this
oh oh no why oh no there's also a lot of
is that is that it like a fungal stats
fungal spore not fungal food okay yeah
yes yes yes where's the meat where's the
meat
but made back on me that's more like
snack okay alright alright I think it's
time to calm down a little bit you guys
are getting a little rambunctious and as
much as I appreciate rambunctious niss
like this is a serious situation
this is starvation we're talking about
building flooded oh god no
why is flooded but it's so little water
okay it's like a hundred and fifty
kilograms of water but it's so little
water it's not that much it's not that
much
okay all right problem still we're not
producing enough oxygen but that's okay
because frankly who needs it
oxygen is overrated we all know this I
know this
oh look at this it's a solid buffer a
blow that's up offer a blow that is a
solid buffer a blue oh that's nice okay
this is good the HVAC Tsar running again
it's getting down to a nice temperature
in here it's getting what's the
temperature of the gas inside the pipes
Oh 15 degrees okay we've got 23 thousand
calories we're feeling good we've looked
good I look good we all look good we all
look good it's great it's great it's
great it's great it's chika it's great
it's great chika good girl good girl
chika
you're such a good girl you wanna come
over here you want to say hi you want to
say hi everybody wants to say hi chica
Copa cover chika come on come on come on
come on come on little higher there we
go there she we're doing it chika we're
doing it we're winning we're winning
we're winning we're winning
it only took a little murder but don't
worry if we were in a starvation
situation I would never kill you I would
rather die I'd rather die Oh
[Music]
would rather die I don't know if that's
a comforting thing sweetie bumpkin right
here it's a sweetie bumpkin okay go on
good girl
now crisis has been averted for now we
still have the issue that it's too hot
so what I'm going to do is I'm still
gonna build the I'm still gonna build
what I need to build right here to get
myself a nice what would be a ham let me
do some whoa well let me do some
counting here one one two three four
five six what's what's uh ninety six
eight by twelve okay so one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve so eleven so it's gonna be
slightly smaller than what it needs to
be but that's fine I don't know why I've
got fire poles here why do I have fire
percent like they're needed that
whatever they're their final okay so one
two three four five six is it seven
eight up and then we'll make it like
this so that we're gonna have this will
be the farming quote unquote Farm
station kind of thing going on here
we're gonna put food I'm gonna make
station we need a station we need a
farming station right here
I don't know how farming stations work
I'm just guessing at this point a
farming station there we're gonna build
it's gonna be a multi-level thing but
we're not gonna have these we're gonna
have hydroponic tiles because that's
important we're gonna have so this is
gonna be a hydroponic farm not just a
farm a hydroponic farm so that we can
save space and put more plants in here
and then man I really wish that was not
there wolframite why are you making that
out of wolframite it won't make
something like that out of wolframite
make it out of gold amalgam I don't care
whatever all right that'll be a good
start and then I'm gonna see what we can
do as far as do everything else that
we're gonna need which we're gonna need
a lot
[Music]
okay then they'll build that whenever
they get the chance to build that Oh
what wait wait one two three four what's
so what's nine time 11s would be too
high one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten yeah it's fine it's fine
I could probably make it a little bigger
I could probably we don't need a it's
fine it's fine it is just an experiment
I'm just learning I'm learning everybody
I'm learning this is a learning
experience all of this the murder the
starvation why aren't you who's starving
better traval no go get some goddamn
food you idiot go get some food eat it
you fool okay all right but all that
aside so what we have to do now is we
have to number one forget this thing for
a while cuz what I was trying to do here
I was trying to create a system where I
was able to get unlimited power but I
didn't even realize that this thing here
needed an operator the whole time so the
way this steam thing works is I this was
a nightmare by the way this whole
operation here a nightmare a goddamn
nightmare but I did it nonetheless so
what it is is I've got magma here and I
probably should and that should be just
climbing in temperature right that's how
that would work either way this is magma
here this is putting dirty water here to
boil it into steam but the steam isn't
hot enough that's the problem right now
the steam isn't hot enough but there's
also the sour gas in here that operates
as like the sour gas is petroleum that's
been superheated to gaseous form and
what's weird is if you boil crude oil
it'll turn into sour gas but then it
condenses back into usable petroleum
which is weird cuz then you wouldn't
even need a petroleum refinery to make
petroleum which is a whole nother thing
but not what I'm where all my god sour
gas is everywhere over here Oh God
weights our gasps wait Oh oh no what is
that
oh god it's everywhere it's everywhere
wait sorry gasps does it not Oh God
oh no it's sour gas doesn't condense
back circuits is just sour gas oh okay
all right
it's final let's just forget it for now
what we're gonna do what we're gonna do
and listen I'm saying what we're gonna
do what we're gonna do what we're gonna
do is very simple wait Oh gonna pump the
sour gas right out of here don't pump it
right out of here I should never have
done what I shouldn't have done anything
like this I didn't know okay so when I
was building this I didn't know that
sour gas was a thing I didn't even know
what's our gas was and I thought up
until two minutes ago
that sour gas condensed back into
petroleum but it don't it don't it
really really don't it really really
really really really really don't it
don't it don't it really really don't
okay all that aside
all that aside we're not gonna worry
about it right now because why worry
worrying is just a byproduct of stress
and I'm not stressed what I'm doing is
I'm sending my duplicates to space
because that way they get the [ __ ] out
of here they'll never have to deal with
any of this [ __ ] ever again and it'll
all be good right yeah so with that
being said we can okay you hear that
everybody we can be okay and we are
gonna be okay because I say we're gonna
be okay so don't worry about it all
right all right so let's focus on
getting our petitions in the space now
this is probably gonna open up an entire
new problem set that I don't even know
about because I don't even know how to
deal with getting to space I've never
done it before so who knows how this is
gonna go but I want to build like a
telescope oh that's cool oh it's pretty
cool okay so I want to build like a
telescope that's cool gas intake pipe
oxygen neat must be exposed to space
that's cool
I like that that's neat let's virtual
planetarium that's neat oh I like that I
like that so let's put the telescope
right there oh we need spacesuits
that's okay first foremost Oh before we
do anything else we need ourselves some
space suits
[Laughter]
I'm channeling my inner Eric Dixon
let's just break down in tears every few
seconds but it's fine but it's fine yes
I'm gonna ignore the gaseous death
marching upon me yeah
what's what's the deal it's just sour
gas that's not problematic just because
it seems to be literally at every
density level including oxygen doesn't
mean doesn't mean that it's problem it
doesn't mean that it's a problem we are
not doomed it's fine just just just
ignore it
all right the other reason that I had to
livestream this today is because later
today they're releasing another update
to the game and I will not have all of
my glorious progress inhibited by this
[ __ ] I will not I've come too far I
have come too far I have come too far I
have come too far to be stopped now I'm
gonna see this into the ground or I'm
going to die trying and as it stands
right now it looks like I'm gonna die
trying so everybody just put it out of
your mind there's nothing to stress
about okay whatever clock for I would
kill every duplicate in my base camera
and I would I would kill every duplicate
in my base right now is there an end
goal of this game not dying that's the
end goal so everybody shush your tuchus
shushes your tuchus and let me work cuz
ah the genius is about to unleash my
genius the genius is about to unleash my
genius you hear me you hear you hear me
it doesn't seem like you're here god
damn it I broke the oh no I broke down
oh no I broke down my
down the thing that's good don't spit
all right rock granulator you know we
don't need a rock granulator we need we
don't need a rock crane glacier we need
a space an exosuit Forge that's an
exosuit Forge we're gonna get to space I
just want to get to space that's don't
know don't your job but you didn't you
didn't fit it don't don't go on break
now okay whatever it's fine I'm not
worried about it because you know why
I'll tell you why because I am a baller
shot caller wolframite in this yeah
Wolfram I it's in the metal thing okay
everybody you're getting to getting to
crazy
you're just getting too crazy and I
won't allow it I won't have it I won't
have this craziness I won't have this
this nonsense we are better than this
we're better than this we're better than
this and you guys know it so get it put
on your big-boy pants and let's do this
okay exosuit checkpoint I'm imagining
there doesn't need to be more than five
people here so I'm just gonna put that
what can I can what yeah whatever
jet suit oh wait do I need a jet suit or
do I need an exosuit
I need to put petroleum it I'm not doing
that okay we're doing exosuits
cuz no well [ __ ] we're doing exosuits
because I'm not putting petroleum in
anything what what oh god no there's a
volt there's a frickin turn around there
put this here and and this we're gonna
be in space okay there's just no tears
only space now you won't have to worry
about a damn thing cuz we'll be in space
we're gonna be in space and that's all
that matters
nothing matters except the fact that we
will be in space and when we're in space
all our dreams come true
it's true all our dreams all our dreams
are gonna come true all our dreams our
dreams are gonna come true
aye our dreams they're not gonna just be
dreams our dreams are gonna be so
everything that we've ever hoped for
wanted needed even all this good
dream enos that we have that's that's
just us veces our lives us who we are
what we have where we poop it's us our
dreams that's who we are
and with dreams I don't know where I'm
going with this one Oh everybody shush
shush your faces
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's okay
it's all right everybody calm down it's
just your tuchus calm down everybody
calm down
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo sagas still creeping
up on us I like I like I like it I like
it it's nice I like sour gas is cool
this is still not hot enough we get no
power I always stall my house did
everything I've ever had to try to get
this to work but it doesn't and that's
fine that's fine that's fine you know
what that is fine there's only this much
magma that is of a roasting temperature
fine we've only got death coming at us
from multiple angles all of my own
devising by the way I did all of this I
did all this so what I got to do do we
need to make wait I need to queue up
people to make the
exosuits we're gonna build this exosuit
thing and then we're gonna build some
spacesuits and then we are going to have
a good time we're gonna party and it's
going to be it's gonna be great it's
gonna be so good it's gonna be so good
it's gonna be so good thank you I know
it's a cool base it's gonna be so good
all right what else I need to do is we
need to create gas cuz it's got to be
like it's a ventilated thing you got to
put oxygen in the thing I don't know
where we're gonna get the gas soon but I
know the gas is gonna come from
somewhere down here ish somewhere maybe
I could just I could probably just it's
already there it's already set up so I'm
going to use it power that's another
thing that we need power is important
power power very important powers yep
that's where the power is gonna come
from I'm sure that that's fine too
also I'm sure that that's also too fine
very also fine
what link is that on one more manual
generator oughta be perfectly enough for
that bad boy to be everything it ever
dreamed of being right right okay
things are not going good guys I just
want to let you know let me level with
you you think things ain't good things
ain't good I don't know I'm slipping
slowly into madness okay all right we're
fine everything's good everything's fine
why am I worried all right at most suit
does this mean that they can go into
space I'm gonna assume the answer is yes
I think the answer is yes as much as I
would like flight flight sounds super
cool flight sounds super neato but we're
gonna do a search and that'll be fine
that'll be good that'll be fine I ain't
[ __ ] worried what's the plan does
puff gotta play I can't do a Dutch
impression huh
all right so then whenever we get suits
we're just gonna deliver some suits up
here and then our dreams will no longer
be dreams ladies and gentlemen our dream
what is that what is that
gravitas what Frankie's bluff Frankie
give me my Frankie Frankie we have here
sure I'd be down to get lunch I just
found out Frank he's one of those people
who takes pictures of all their food and
uploads them to some dumb blog somewhere
you have to come to lunch with us and
see they spend so long taking picture
the food gets cold and they have to ask
a waiter to warm it up again it's so
funny that's hilarious and mean results
from a not atomic on everything went
well mr. Clint talk Oh
dangerous name was reluctant at first
but she has little alternative given the
nature of her work she can begin at your
convenient there's all this like there's
lure in this game by the way if you
didn't know there's lure there is lure
and it is strewn about the game in like
bits and pieces everywhere I'm gonna put
a priority on this because I feel like
you know it's break time but whatever
okay so tomorrow is it getting colder it
is it's getting colder guys it's getting
colder
all that sour gas but we're gonna be
like the UH what's that the Mass Effect
race that has to wear spacesuits all the
time we're gonna be like those people
Tali whatever tally tally of the nothing
Drew and I know we're gonna be like them
we're gonna be wearing spacesuits all
the time that's gonna be us that's gonna
be us
they quarians yeah quarians we're gonna
be like the quarians if there's our guys
ever we can beat the sour gas by simply
having space suits all the time that'll
be us I'll be look at all this look at
and it's gonna be nice and cold oxygen -
it's gonna be so cold it's gonna be birf
rigid and so cold where is the space it
Oh God who's stressed Oh God everybody's
stressed ada why are you stressed why
are you stressed Oh No
why are you stressed data soggy feet Oh
God is everyone really is stressed
because they got soggy feet is that
really what's getting people down in the
dumps is that really the worst of our
problems right now is soggy feet is that
really is that really all right you know
what that's fine cuz I'm gonna build you
guys the best break room you've ever
seen in your life you guys are gonna
have the greatest break room that's ever
been broken I'm gonna give you some [ __ ]
and you're gonna stuff it in your pants
and it's gonna be great and you're gonna
love it
you're gonna love everything about it
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
it you're gonna love this you're gonna
have a jukebox even though it takes help
shut up and deal with it I'm not gonna
build you [ __ ] just take a shower and
clean up I can't help the soggy because
we got it falling apart it was so nice
it was so nice literally the second
before we started this adventure it was
nice it was nice everyone was happy
everyone was happy everyone was so happy
it was nice it was nice we were happy
everyone was nice I'm a building massage
parlor the farm I'm a building unless
there's parlor you're gonna like it
we're gonna get a size Clinic 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 4 times 9 is 36 that's
plenty
there we go nice put it here there now
we're gonna put nice paintings built
badou poop poop yeah what else and then
we're gonna put a nice block and there
we go there we go we're good
we're good we're good we're good
and then we're gonna put a bandage n
reiter right here right here not too too
- OH - now we're gonna put two batteries
here and then botta bing botta boom
badda there
run-run those bad boys through here
what the [ __ ] run the bad boys here
there and bada-bing bada-boom we got
ourselves on the sushi our and look at
that so much stress relieving you don't
even know how little stress you're gonna
have why do we not have exosuits yet why
do we not have they're right here
they're all here just deliver up there
we need them we need them so badly
wait I'm so badly just get it right
there just put it right there it's fine
it's fine it's fine okay
it's fine they're gonna get it there
it's only been like one cycle since
we've had that it's only been one cycle
I don't know why put these at a priority
six would that help I might help I think
that'll help
I think that'll yeah yeah where you
going where you going where you going
you going to deliver a suit you know Oh
suit suit delivery delivery suit
delivery suit alert suit suit suit
delivery to delivery I think I think
what it is I think what it is is these
things are causing issues with how
priorities they are so I need to get
those not so priority because I think
that's really what's messing with it
that's what's messing with it that's
what's messing with it so we just need
to yeah everything's now right wait you
know who that is
it's traval doe two point nine trip
although two point nine knows what's up
drove although three point nine is a
hero trav although three point nine hero
hero hero hero heroes heroes all of them
yes yes yes yes yes yes gasps yes space
space space space space space we're
getting space
we're gonna be space we're gonna be
spaced we're gonna be space guys we're
gonna be space we're gonna be space and
then we can die happy we're gonna expand
we're gonna space we're gonna be space
we're gonna be space and then we can die
and then I'm gonna die
we're gonna space and then I'm going to
die space then death space and death and
then space and then death and then I
space and then I die and we're going in
space and then death we're going to
space and then we're gonna die sorry the
echo is all off on that one we're cut
space and then we're gonna die we can
die cuz this was my objective from the
get-go just to go to space I wanted to
get to space really badly and now I'm
going to get to space and then I'm going
to die it's fine it's fine
also I'm leaving in a couple days we're
making the big journey back to
Cincinnati by Road it's gonna take about
four days and then we're going to die
good day there we die did we die and
then death is upon us death everybody
loves death everybody does you ask
anybody anywhere what do you think of
death great that's what I say that's
what we all say at least the stress is
going down but who happened to happen
who have to do happen I want a massage
table like that I really did
that's really something there ADA is
having the time of her life
these people are getting exercised
providing afraid all right good good
okay all right good okay so why is this
taking so long to dig up in here
I don't know food shortage yeah right as
if he's about to get so much food get
out of here
shut up we're fine everything's fine
look at that see Oh what is that well
that's some garbage come on come on you
come on you there we go there we go
there we go now that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about
that is what I'm talking about
we're so close
we're gonna be in space alert service
breach the region is extremely in the
hospital and I could easily lose
resources to the vacuum of space that's
fine that's fine
dig what throwin throne you didn't Rowan
Rowan
oh oh whoa oh whoa
I'm changing the name of this changing
the name of this I'm changing the name
of this stream game but video whatever
whenever you're watching it in jail
change this change it to we're in wait
[Music]
[Laughter]
we made it to space guys
this is so big for me I've never made it
this far in this game ever in ever I've
never made it this far is that just
gonna keep happening what the hell
that's oh my god
that's what is this why is this here
guys I've never ever ever made it this
far
ever ever oh I'm so happy I'm so happy
and now we can die you don't understand
it's taking so many hours just to get to
this moment
Oh Oh God and I could easily die by just
opening this these these um this
airlocks to the vacuum of space and I
would die and then we die maybe that's
for the best
maybe that's a good way to go maybe that
is maybe maybe true maybe it's true
maybe true maybe
guys I can't believe but I've learned so
much that's the thing right this game in
this game what makes this game so great
is that you learn every time you learn
until you fail and then you learn you
take what you learn from those failures
and then you start over again and you do
it better like I learned so much so much
about creating a base getting HVAC
management up getting water management
how to do it properly I did it
improperly but also I did some things
properly how to get like how did how to
keep things moving how to not die so
quickly I learned so much in this small
like in this small world that the next
time if I started up which probably
won't be soon because I am so of so
ready to be done but you know what I
mean you know what I mean I'm not gonna
restart now I haven't even died yet let
me die at least let me die he just let
me die and then then then then then
it'll be fine
then it'll be fine and I did it all
myself I did it if even with the barrage
of people trying to backseat gave me to
death he did it all myself I learned it
I learned it I learned I did that all
this every tile every tile I placed
every tile in here I clicked every
single one of you as old the sour gas
that was a lesson to learn so lesson
learned
don't let oil get heat up don't let oil
get heat up and then you be fine that's
what I learned from that but
I learned it I learn did this I learned
it I learned it and now I'm gonna
destroy it all oh oh I can't believe it
okay but before I destroy it all I know
that I'm going to destroy it all but
let's just assume at least for a little
bit that I don't want to destroy it all
immediately you know what I mean let's
just assume I'm not saying that it's
there
we've there's still some things that we
can do to make this work
I can build a telescope I could build a
rocket you can build a rocket I don't
know where the rocket is where would
even the rocket be rocketry
I haven't even unlocked it ha
Oh steal steal steal how do you make
steel it's probably with the metal
refinery which I don't have lime where
do you get lime where do you get lime
where do you get lime and it British is
so much heat oh my god but look at him
hiren oh okay we got to go hang on we
got to go we got to go in here because
there's something here that I want to
see there's some [ __ ] going on here what
the hell what the hell what the hell
what is this that's so cool that's so
cool bright and cheerful is it because
you saw Spurs is it because you saw
space probably if you see space you're
gonna be real you're gonna be real
amazed oh my god so cool
what's the decor like in that place oh
it's beautiful
oh it's beautiful it's beautiful nice
obsidian tiles drywall drywall drywall
food George we're gonna die okay I
didn't build the farm I forgot I was
trying to build a farm here that's right
okay let's at least try to keep it going
for just a little longer I don't know
how much longer put just a little that's
all we really want that's what I scream
you scream we all scream for ice cream
I'm screaming you're screaming we're all
screaming in space everybody screams
my head hurts I've got a headache
but it's okay losing food we're not
losing food look at all this growth look
at all this growth vibrant life life
vibrant life life life vibrant life here
you do it you're doing what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing I don't know what it's doing but
it's doing something but it doesn't
matter vibrant beautiful life life what
am i building this out of granite why do
I build everything out of granite I
don't want to build it well let's build
it out of I guess we have the most
granite whatever okay what can we put
here what can we put here bomb see
that's not with pinch of pepper oh it's
got to be upside down for pinch of
pepper oh but it can be made hot but
it's not hot in here not anymore
it's cold it's cool it's beautiful it's
so cold
blossom seed fungal spore no that needs
no but I can't make that
alright sure it's fine
in these life and his life more meal
with that's all just more meal wood
that's all we need not enough material
just more meal wood why not
it's fine my duplicants can get by with
eating for them I did this for them you
know like the Simpsons poster do it for
him
the thermo null for thermo nullifier
wait that's
that's the printing bag introducing the
latest in 3d printing the gravitas home
printing pod we are proud to announce
that printing advancements developed
here in the graph test facility will
soon bring new bio-organic production
capabilities to your old home printers
what does that mean for the average
household dinner frustrations are a
thing of the past
simply select any of the pods five
thousand three hundred ninety-eight
pre-program recipes and voila delicious
pot roast ready in only 0.8 seven
seconds prefer the patented family
recipe program your own custom meal
template for an instant taste of home or
old go old-school and create fresh
delicious ingredients and prepare your
own home-cooked meal dinner time has
never been easier projected for
commercial availability early next year
brought to you by gravitas what a mining
gun that's the mining gun bringing your
mining operations into the 23rd century
with new gravitas personal excavators
improve particle condensers reduce raw
volume for more efficient product
shipping and that's good for your bottom
line license for industrial use only
resale of gravitas equipment mayor carry
a fine of up to $200,000 under the
global restoration act this is the
company that made this is the company
this is the company that made lor sod
phone up mad pat get me some give me
some theories about this [ __ ] look at
this so originally the printing thing
wasn't even meant for this but then how
did this how did this thing get here how
did it get there how did it get there
how did it get there how did it get
there guys how did it get there
guys how does get there that how did
this how did this get here
what is why is this here how did that
get there why that means those ends
ha who how did that then why is this
here what is this okay all right
theory here comes markiplier its theory
here we go get ready it's about to go
down it's about to go down all right so
all right so so so so so food Jordans
that's fine all right so here's my
theory here's my theory this asteroid
it's not so much an asteroid it's a
fragment of a destroyed home planet
earth went kaboom II earth went kaboom
and then this is all that remains
it's a last-ditch effort to keep the
human race going through cloning cloning
and that's why the printing pot is down
I don't know never be mad I didn't plan
ahead I don't know any of that I can't
do it but it's fine it's fine it's fine
so there's new everything it's amazing
okay all right I'm out of breath okay
I'm not okay I'm not okay I'm not okay
in no way shape or form am i okay I'm
not okay
all right I'm not okay I'm not okay
okay I'm not okay I'm not okay all right
so so I and I'm a save as new save the
all right guys
I'm about to do something real stupid
just you know how I'm dumb listen to me
listen to me
listen to me I am curious as to what
will happen if I were to say open
[Laughter]
curiosity cuz you know life is about
experimenting you make mistake you get
dirty clothes ms Frizzles slogan for
like the Magic School Bus what was it I
forget was it you get dirty you make
mistakes and you open I'm just curious
to see how quickly we're about to open a
good opener up
oh it's break time okay it's break so
they get one more sleepy one more sleep
beat they get one more little sleepy
sweet let's open this one's gotta be
opened Oh what are we crazy this one's
open the pod bay doors that's right here
we go listen I'm not crazy I'm not crazy
I'm not crazy I'm not I'm not crazy
Crazy's not what I am I'm not crazy I'm
just insane I'm not crazy
[Laughter]
we're all gonna die we're all gonna die
take chances make mistakes oh okay it's
fine everybody take your last breath
everybody get ready to hold your breath
this is not gonna be this is gonna be so
anticlimactic I've been a wreck you're
ready to hold your breath here we go
oh no come on there's one more opens
it's open the air over it
there we go and they're open oh [ __ ] oh
God
I saw that
[Laughter]
I'll take the gas well I guess closer
back just like someone someone someone
went crazy in this base I was a flick
and there's nothing I mean there's no
oxygen here maybe that means something
no ice is not in here I guess it's jeez
okay all right well I think that's all
I'm gonna get done for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching I've got
a busy day ahead I've got to prepare a
bunch of videos I've got a record so
much stuff for the trip out there and
then while I'm out there I'm probably
all I'm back in Cincinnati I'm probably
gonna be doing a lot more live streams
so be on the lookout for those thank you
everybody so much for watching i
streamed a lot of this on Twitch getting
to this point I streamed over on Twitch
I stream at odd hours but if you want to
go see streams over there go follow me
twitch.tv slash markiplier I stream all
the time over there so check that out
you guys take care have a wonderful day
thank you so much for being a part of
this and have a lovely rest of your day
take care love you thanks for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
da ba da ba da da da